Romijn we interviewed Bill Duke or the
second time he gave us a wonderful
interview both times and we had a video
we wanted to play and get your reaction
okay here we go
I think where all of us are everything
and people say why can you say that I'm
a woman with a child I'm not a murderer
okay
suppose somebody just came up and made
sure a baby in the head with a hammer
well what would you car you response to
that if you pick that hammer up no one's
saying you're a murderer and the ones
saying you're anything but you're
everything oh and if you're hired to do
a job the director doesn't hire you to
act like that person
the director hires you to become that
person right and that's something that
most people understand by acting I think
it's not I don't that word is annoying
because it means you're pretending
acting is not pretending
acting is becoming it's surrendering to
the spirit of whatever your that
character you're describing is so think
I'll stage right that's when you're in
the middle you've given part of yourself
up to be the character but your ego and
your fear and paranoia is watching how
you give it up and tries to control the
shape of that giving up right but real
actors like the ones that I adore the
Kate Winslet's and the Meryl Streep's
and the denzel's when he's really in it
and the Sam Jackson's and
philip Seymour Hoffman's and the Jeffrey
writes and when those people go there
there's no there's nobody there except
that character and that's admirable it
takes courage and people don't
understand because sometimes you not
control your you want to ride if the
trust and the person you trust the
director to say that I ride right what
do you think cuz you don't stand outside
and look at your ride you ride and
that's what real great actors do flop
scene one half is when my favorite
actress of all time I think he was
brilliant oh yeah can someone still be
great and have stage fright they can be
great and have stage fright making me
really good and have stage fright right
but to surrender totally to the moment
and to totally respond to what the other
person that you're acting with is doing
that's her that takes courage you're not
watching yourself anymore you're
watching the person you're with and the
scene you're not watching how you react
to what they do you're responding like
we're talking right now I'm not trying
to be a special anything I'm just
responding to what you're asking me
that's what acting should be one of my
great acting teachers when I was a very
young actor I asked a similar question
he said I'm gonna make it real simple
for you he said it's like falling into
darkness imagine just falling into
darkness backward no control of your
landing it was right you're gonna be
caught or not just a fault embrace it
well well suppose I rock back there or
suppose there's a I don't know no
pillows and just hard floor the writer
is saying to you I want you to fall into
darkness backward I'm giving you all the
description the director and I of who
the character is we've had rehearsals
and discussions about who this human
being is I do not want you to describe
them to me I want you to become them by
falling into darkness backward right can
you do that oh I agree with him I would
take it a step further on one of them
when he says becoming instead of instead
of it acting you become the person I
mean yeah it's just a kind of wordplay
but I would say instead of becoming you
be the person you be what you are
I've studied um I think I've studied
every major technique Stanislavski the
method because they all come from
standards off Stanislavski well they all
come from Stanislavski every form of or
method or style you know are originates
the modern acting originates from
Stanislavski and I've studied all of
them and now the one I recognised to me
that works best for me I mean you use
bits and pieces of everything but the
one that I the one technique that I
really use more of or really is Meisner
because Meisner is is you be you are
that person and one thing that they
always stress to us in Meisner when I
was studying Meisner was don't ever say
my character my character wants to do
this so my character is that or this
that no yes I am this I am that see
which which takes you beyond becoming
because see to me when you become when
you're becoming or you to become this
character to me you're still in it I
agree with everything basically you you
still outside somewhat of the character
you know you're still kind of outside
but to be that the character then you're
inside all the way and that's part of
what he's saying about falling backwards
I mean you fought you into it to the
point where it's just you and you just
let go and trust yourself that's what
he's saying but I agree he's a hell of a
actor and director and and it's kind of
funny when he mentioned Denzel
Washington about when Denzel lets him
stuff when he goes into it sometimes in
greatest Denzel Washington here
sometimes I could see he's working and
when he did fences and to be honest to
give him he was directing as well as
acting so he
had to come outside of it to to work
with the other people and especially
Viola Davis who to me is just she's
tremendous she's like she's like them
newer right you said hey just say that
but like she's like the newer Meryl
Streep you know and there's quite a few
I mean Cate Blanchett that's quite a few
and you know I love Daniel day-lewis
Daniel day-lewis to me is the one net
becomes he is more than any other actor
to me as we talked early he is Hawkeye
you know he is crazy I was bill or
whatever from Gangs of New York he is
that he is the oil oil baron that throws
that bowling ball at that boy you know
and actually try to hurt him because
he's so far in that you know he
frightens those people and and all of
those actors like Leonardo DiCaprio and
Paul Dana and all them all of them said
that after working with him and seeing
how he works that took him to a whole
nother level and especially Leonardo
DiCaprio and he did some really nice
stuff when he was a kid you know
basketball tires yeah really nice stuff
but after gangs in New York he took a
step he took a step up to me and when he
did revenant he wasn't he wasn't acting
he wasn't becoming he was that character
I mean for anybody that might not have
seen the movie on when when he goes over
the cliff after the Indian or whatever
were chasing him and the big that big
horse falls over and then the horse
breaks his neck and eyes and he's
screwed up
when he to survive when he cuts debt and
guts dead horse and then takes his
clothes off to make sure he can get that
warmth of the horse he gets inside of
that thing and I mean I'm like I mean
I'm sure you know and they probably but
they didn't have a real horse I don't
believe I don't think he but the fact
that he was able to convey that and get
that into it and when the bear attacked
him I mean you can't just act you can't
say well okay I'm gonna act you have to
be that person at that point he was that
guy getting savage didn't scraped and
beat and just chewed on by that bear I
mean is this was like wow and and he won
the Oscar because he was so far gone
it's like last year another one of my
favorite actors is Gary Oldman Gary
Oldman no matter what he does Gary
Oldman is that person he's not acting or
pretending he is that person even when
he plays Commissioner Gordon in the
Batman franchise he he was Commissioner
Gordon I mean he's done some brilliant I
mean and he just did Winston Churchill I
mean I was just mesmerized he won an
Oscar but I mean I was completely like
wow completely just mesmerized by him
because he was he he became Winston
Churchill and I tell you who I hadn't
seen it yet but this movie Vice with
Christian Bale saw it you saw it and and
from what I'm hearing
he was Dick Cheney excellent and Dick
Cheney I'm sorry I mean whoever's
watching this to change his diabolical
evil person me I mean you know hey I
mean but he became Dick Cheney in the
previews I saw I saw what I saw a movie
a couple of weeks ago I came to know
what it was but they showed to preview a
vice and to let me know
in the show just how far in watching the
watching the trailer of it at the
theater when it's over you can tell when
somebody really connects when everybody
in the theater just give me to watch the
movie with air forces you know when you
and you get it you hit that buzz in the
in the audience you know sometimes you
it'll be a laughter on something really
silly and funny kind of trailer you know
they connect so you laugh but when I saw
that everyone's like hmm because we saw
Dick Cheney and then you know the thing
where you know you sitting in the truck
he's a shoots his friend you know I mean
what did it happen like there's not I
mean you know but it's just it was just
really all the way in and and and I
think that's what the whole thing about
acting is or being an actor and which is
what I find so so great about this and
you can never ever master this you never
master this and people said what do you
mean you don't master know you know ever
master this you always you always have
something to learn it's not like it's
not like well got that down you ain't
because you're only as good as your last
performance and especially so in theater
theater theater theater is the one place
where you get instant gratification and
instant critiques
well film you know you can do 100 takes
or whatever what he can edit it together
and then six months later or whatever
when they release it didn't you find out
or you'll get your critique but on stage
you get it immediately so anybody and
I've been there it's like all actors
well you don't you do a great
performance one night and there's like
the next night yeah yeah
you know I was they really liked me they
loved me you know I did I was tremendous
in the next night fall flat on your face
which is a lesson to learn it's like you
have to commit every moment you out
there the performance the performance is
gonna be different no to performance
I've been in stuff and plays and shows
and stuff with people especially
musicals it always is different but most
places and I've had actors and younger
actors and people saying even some older
actors say I didn't do this right it's
not like it was last night no it's not
like that it's gonna be different which
is the challenge of it and which to me
is like the blessing and everything of
it in fact that
yeah I can't master this because I've
always been a type coming up where I
would get bored with stuff especially in
school I would get bored with it by the
time I got to college and I went over
some of the stains same stuff I had done
in high school I was like okay this is
college I mean time I'm gonna go over
this I know this okay and a lot of that
stuff they wouldn't give me a new
perspective on it if wasn't giving me oh
this is a new way to do it which would
excite me to the point of oh is
something different that's all the same
so eventually I'm like okay but when I
got into this each time is different
which thrills to this day I'm thrilled
it's different these time and I got to
make sure that I don't screw it up or if
I do so be it
I gotta use that you know when I first
got into business if I made a mistake or
if somebody I knew we were younger
actors you make a mistake you might show
the audience that you make a mistake
because of your reaction to the mistake
but when you are that person when you
are a character in you all the way in
you can deal with that because you make
mistakes you make mistakes when we
talking I mean I've bitched a couple of
times here but that's real yeah it's not
like okay I got to go back over that
line because I said that wrong no no you
have to work through that it's to the
point now and I tried I mean hopefully
it works but I try when I make a mistake
doing something live then I use it to
the point where the audience doesn't
know I made a mistake
that's when you really locked in and
when you are that character when it's
something that you are and and you're
gonna stumble
I know actors that fall apart after this
stumble oh I stumbled over the line it's
like you stumble over the lines all day
long you stumbling walking in here you
know you hit your foot on the door or
something you know you your elbow hits
it's like you're not just walking in
there I didn't hit anything that was
perfect oh you make mistakes all over
that's that's what makes it real and
when you do that and you just continue I
was in the show years ago where I played
um I play Skeeter - just
you